e dal 24 luglio 2015 che volevo fare
questo video giffoni film festival 2015
immaginatevi di essere lì tra in mezzo
alla folla anche in mezzo alla giulia
perché no
vengono presentati film di tutti i tipi
ci sono ospiti giganteschi
internazionali c'è tom felton c'è mark
ruffalo c'è martin freeman c'è orlando
bloom tutti a presentare i loro film i
loro progetti a firmare autografi si
respira un'aria di festa un'aria allegra
e sono tutti contentissimi di poter
partecipare a questa edizione ci sono
giurati da tutto il mondo film da tutto
il mondo 3.600 giurati da 50 paesi nel
mondo 156 film selezionati su oltre
4.200 produzione vengono proiettate
delle anteprime come and men e
capolavori acclamati dalla critica come
pixels c'è anche un leccio con il trio
medusa
ad un certo punto da lontano senti degli
schiamazzi e vedi 4 influencer con
apparentemente niente in comune
lì a presentare un film uscito un
pochino in sordina nelle sale
cinematografiche che probabilmente
nessuno si ricorda per evitare che mi
scoppia una luce davanti
eviteremmo di nominare bordello e poi
arriviamo secondo me al gran
protagonista di quella edizione e io
sono molto triste che non si parli di
più di quel fin lì un po perché non lo
conosce nessuno veramente ogni volta che
ne parla nessuno sa cosa sia anche
perché un film per bambini italiano
quindi proprio la gente lo ignora
completamente oppure al massimo lo usa
per tenere aperte le porte cigolanti
questo lungometraggio non solo è
incredibile ma anche vinto il premio
come miglior film della sua categoria
più sei normale per un esordio alla
regia di mi colpa a lucca però perché il
vincitore del giffoni film festival 2015
la critica l'ha accolto molto
tiepidamente e io le sto facendo un
intero video dio mio
non vedevo l'ora di raccontarvi
[Musica]
devo parlarvi del film e devo
raccontarvelo dall'inizio alla fine però
voglio fare una cosa voglio fare un
piccolo gioco con voi io vi racconto
tutto ma ho metterò un singolo
particolare che è il motivo per cui
siamo qui e soprattutto chi conosce
grotto non deve scrivere niente nei
commenti perché so che c'è gente che
ancor prima di far partire il video
subito va nei commenti a vedere un po
l'andazzo voi non dovete far capire
niente
la trama è molto semplice i goonies o
meglio quel tipo di pacchetto
cinematografico gruppo di amici che va
alla ventura si mette nei casini e poi
si salvano tutti
è questa la nostra forza giusta
incredibilmente prima di stringere
things cinque piccoli giovanissime amici
che hanno nomi da bocciofila carlo
chiara aldo look e michele abbiamo le
caratterizzazioni standard di ogni
singolo personaggio che si possono
trovare in qualsiasi film per ragazzi
c'è il belloccio numero uno quello
violento c'è il belloccio numero due
quello un po più sano di mente c'è la
spalla emotiva che ovviamente e
femminile perché non possono fare
nient'altro che questo tipo di film c'è
il nardone che costantemente viene
invitato da gruppi di amici che non
hanno niente in comune con lui lo odiano
tutti ma a quanto pare la vita è una
merda e quindi meglio male accompagnati
che soli e poi ovviamente il personaggio
comico del gruppo che serve un po ad
alleggerire le tensioni dei viaggi delle
avventure dei nostri personaggi che voi
ve lo state immaginando in un modo ed è
esattamente così
grasso perché non c'è niente di più
divertente di un bambino che in futuro
potrebbe avere dei problemi di salute
per far ridere lo spettatore valeri
questa come ho detto prima è uscito un
anno prima di senje tings ma le
similitudini tra i due personaggi sono
incredibili però non è più divertente il
nostro scoreggia è un po come la paranza
di bambini di roberto saviano al nardò
ne viene fatto fare un rito di
iniziazione viene costretto ad entrare
in una casa abbandonata da solo al buio
rischiando di farsi male boia dai suoi
futuri amici una casa tra l'altro in cui
c'è una teca con teschio
umano all'interno che lui dovrebbe
prendere purtroppo per noi non verrà mai
approfondita dalla trama del perché
qualcuno abbia messo questa cosa
inquietantissimo all'interno della casa
perché il nostro protagonista precipita
in un buco e sparisce nel nulla
gli altri tre bambini dicono vabbè che
facciamo ormai le morto è andato
facciamo che andiamo via tra una
quindicina d'anni torniamo con le forze
dell'ordine ma fortunatamente arriva
chiara che dice no ragazzi dobbiamo
salvarlo altrimenti questa diventa una
trama per un fumetto di zero calcare
cercano di arrovellarsi con una corda e
delle assi di legno per calarsi giù in
questo pozzo nell'oblio del mondo ma
purtroppo crolla tutto e cadono anche
loro da alcune inquadrature il buco
sembra che sia alto 450 metri e loro
siano caduti direttamente dal k2 però
nessuno si fa niente anche il verdone
che è caduto all'inizio si è soltanto
sbucciato un pochino il ginocchio e
tutto il resto della trama è come
facciamo ad andare via
visitiamo le grotte purtroppo non
abbiamo cibo non abbiamo acqua come
sopravviviamo facciamo come alive i
sopravvissuti ci mangiamo tra di noi
magari non è il caso ci sono anche le
classiche scintille di trama per esempio
due personaggi che litigano a turi che
si baciano quello intelligente ma non
simpatico che dice tutte cose che a
nessuno frega e tutti lo odiano lo
vorrebbero massacrare perché sono lì
sotto a causa sua
il bambino in carne che nasconde il cibo
agli altri perché se lo vuole pappare
solo lui perché ricordiamolo è in
sovrappeso e questo fa molto ridere
potevano essere zuccheri per tutti ma
non lasciamoli morire male ad un certo
punto in queste grotte una delle
stalagmiti prende vita e diventa questa
aberrazione della natura chiamata grotto
è una creatura simil antropomorfa mezza
liena che si unisce al gruppo nessuno si
stupisce neanche più di tanto che ci sia
questa cosa qui e tra l'altro i bambini
l'hanno chiamato grotto perché l'hanno
trovato in una grotta e vincitore del
giffoni film festival 2015 c'è la
classica divisione dove cercano
un'uscita più facilmente fortunatamente
grotto non è un film girato da quentin
tarantino perché altrimenti sappiamo
come sarebbe finita sarebbe
sopravvissuta solo lei con
un'inquadratura sui piedi dopo mille
peripezie verso il finale riescono
finalmente a trovare un'uscita nel senso
vedono una luce ma grotto è un
grandissimo figlio di [ __ ] e non le
vuole far scappare perché probabilmente
ha vissuto centinaia di migliaia di anni
da solo e ha detto vabbè questi sono un
po in [ __ ] ti però potrebbero
diventare i miei amici e al pubblico non
può far altro che sciogliersi il colore
dirgli sei un bastardo
a un certo punto dopo quattro settimane
che praticamente loro sono bloccati lì
chiara sviene e nessuno sa come fare
perché non hanno cibo non hanno acqua e
a tutti viene in mente una cosa come fa
grotto a nutrirsi semplice si sdraia a
terra e prendo il nutrimento dalle rocce
quindi lo fanno anche loro e non succede
assolutamente nulla
piccolo dettaglio che avreste potuto
immaginare il nerd sta tutto il tempo
con il nintendo due di esse in mano
cercando tra l'altro di connettersi ad
internet 40 metri sotto terra
tra l'altro grotto è vero che sembra
fatto di playboy
però ci sta diciamo nell'ambiente alla
fine fa parte di una grotta quindi non
poteva essere fatto altrimenti un po
meno bene la foglia che dall'esterno
entra nella grotta per far capire a loro
guardate che c'è una via d'uscita e
finalmente il nostro quintetto riesce ad
uscire salutare grotto e lasciarsi tutta
questa avventura spaventosi ma alle
spalle e tutto si conclude scoprendo che
era una premonizione dichiara non è che
hai avuto un altro ha detto ai sogni
premonitori non solo non è successo
niente di tutto quello che abbiamo visto
per un'ora e mezza ma nonostante lei
l'abbia visto e abbia capito quanto
pericoloso sia andarci decide di andarci
comunque è uno spin off degli 6 di final
destination vincitore come miglior film
nella sua categoria
e questo è gruppo ed io ho lasciato
fuori un piccolissimo particolare il
modulo in cui grotto comunica con
altri
[Musica]
[Applauso]
no
[Musica]
[Applauso]